there were so many of us like young
people it was like Natasha Leon and
Gabby Hoffman and live
and Edward Norton goldon Lucas hos Lucas
hos it was just like Al all of us
running around Paris having fun together
I mean it really was an absolute dream
it was and yet I heard recently that you
said if your kids or a kid wanted to get
into the business what would your
reaction be cuz I know what mine is yeah
I feel like they should wait until
they're grown-ups I totally agree I had
a great experience me
well I had a lot of different
experiences but I feel like it's lucky
that it wasn't very bad it doesn't have
a good track record
no